The John Wick franchise keeps raising the
bar at the box office and reaching new heights
with its stunts – but there's one thing
the series has never been able to overcome,
until now.
Warning: major spoilers ahead for "John Wick:
Chapter 4."
"You ready, John?"
"...Yeah."
The first three "John Wick" movies successfully
hooked and maintained their audience with
a simple, repeatable recipe – John Wick
vs. a lot of doomed assassins.
That winning formula was only limited by Keanu
Reeves' sheer will and director Chad Stahelski's
violent imagination.
There is a plot behind the violence, but it's
fair to say that it's not what the audience
is there for.
As you watch the Boogeyman stab his way out
of a literal knife museum, normal narrative
concerns such as story progression and character
motivation take a back seat to the once-in-a-lifetime
spectacle of it all.
In what other story would the hero deliberately
provoke a horse to kick their enemy — twice?
What other movie would spend nearly two minutes
showing you a man falling down every single
step leading toward Sacre Coeur It's best
not to sweat the little things when you revisit
the Continental Hotel — instead, you should
just enjoy the ride, even if you're not quite
sure what's keeping it going in the first
place.
Unfortunately, when one does stop to think
about the finer parts of this series' story,
it's hard to ignore one fact: for all the
ass-kicking action, John Wick is one of the
most passive characters in modern cinema.
In a genre defined by heroes taking the initiative,
he spends most of the three sequels in a completely
reactionary place.
Instead of trying to accomplish a concrete
goal, he's mostly running around trying not
to die.
For a series with less to offer, this would
be a damning issue.
For "John Wick," it's a problem they don't
really need to solve.
And yet, in "John Wick: Chapter 4," they solved
it anyway.
The narrative thrust of the original "John
Wick" film is both simple and effective.
John wants to kill the men that killed his
dog and stole his car, and his bloodlust will
not be satiated until he does so.
This goal is largely accomplished by the end
of the first film and completely exhausted
by the opening moments of the second.
In order to justify another "John Wick" adventure,
the series runs into a minor problem: how
do you organically find motivation for a character
who essentially has nothing to live for?
His wife is gone, his car is destroyed, and
his quest for vengeance is through.
What else is there for John Wick to accomplish
but his own death?
"What?"
Though the three chapters that follow the
first film are each more thrilling than the
last, John's lack of motivation beyond an
indiscriminate thirst for violence and revenge
caused the quieter, emotional beats to feel
a bit weightless.
In "John Wick: Chapter 4," however, characters
like Caine, Winston, and even the Marquis
finally force John to confront the emptiness
of his quest.
The filmmakers use the climactic duel with
Caine at Sacre Coeur as a point of revelation
for John; both men want to escape from underneath
the High Table, but only one of them has a
life to return to.
It's possible, then, to read John's sparing
of Caine as a recognition of this fact.
By the time John begins to succumb to his
gunshot wounds, a welcome, yet unexpected
feeling of closure begins to set in.
Yes, there are several spin-offs in development
and, yes, there's probably a chance John somehow
survived his "death" at the end of Chapter
4.
But for now, his story is over.
In the closing moments of Chapter 4, the series
has the courage to close the book on the franchise's
story in a way that acknowledges the grim
truth of John's circumstances in an operatic fashion.
Finally, John gets to rest, secure in his
legacy as the most loving husband in the history
of planet Earth.
And if it all ends up leading to him cheating
death for Chapter 5, at least we'll have the
feeling that it's a start of a new story,
and not just another episode of a seemingly
endless quest.
"Can a man like you know peace?
"Why not?"